I my name is frame Chander voila I work
for Wolfram research we are going to
talk about financial data feeds today
and we are going to talk a little bit
about compiler not a little bit but
actually a lot more but what happened
was I was working on an example and I
didn't know I could get it done so but I
did get it done with the compiler so now
there are two presentations and because
it really didn't make sense to just
shoehorn it in the financial data feeds
but anyways there's a link ok it's not
that off but let's let's talk about
financial data feeds so in Wolfram we
have many products we have Wolfram death
straw Mathematica and one of the
projects says well from finance platform
and in that we we have Bloomberg link
and we have reuters link and we have
Bloomberg data license all these
services we'll talk about in detail so
to get more information about what WFP
is you can click on this link it will
take you to the internet and tell you
some more things about it as well sorry
there's built in financial data and what
that means is that you don't need
subscription from any other sources it's
just in Mathematica as built-in you can
evaluate and you can get finance data
right out of the box and the way we
interface that is through entity so you
have financial entity over here I'm not
going to see that but these are some of
the properties that you can query so you
can get 200 the average
row low price and whatnot
some limitations are here you'll always
get delayed data because live data is
premium you have to pay money for it
now subscriptions for your properties no
in so now because we are talking about
external services we kind of have to
talk about the service connect framework
so we have a bunch of services I think
Twitter and pop cam is an example we
connect to these external data services
get stuff from them and in this case pop
cam is actually free so you just built
in and you can get service executes and
it will give you some data about some
chemistry data of compounds and you can
do it asynchronously in 12.1 and
actually in 12 12.1 is not out yet so
you can just submit the query and there
is a callback function and it will set
the response so it happens
asynchronously over here now let's talk
about Bloomberg data license I it's very
interesting service from Bloomberg
because the whole company can get it
they just send you a certificate and
anyone at Wolfram can actually get data
from the data license so this is really
nice if you are a university and you
have big company and Bloomberg terminal
is very expensive so it's like a service
so you connect to it you say tell them
what the fields as if not it will fetch
it from the internet and it uses SSL
certificate as I already went through
that and we after you do connect it kind
of folks into
the entity framework and you can get all
these properties built in has 73
properties this one has 19,000
properties and here's an example of how
to query data from them you can get
really deep data all of this is
completely supported and you'll get nice
associations and so these are all
examples I mean though I don't want to
go into details about each example but
this is the kind of preview that you can
get from doing the data license but
bloom the detail isince is I would call
it the API the service is very much like
ordering from Amazon you order something
they say your order is filled but it
will arrive in two days if you have
Prime right so this is slow so what we
do is we actually have to submit and
after a minute or two you'll get data so
just executing will be quite slow so we
have the framework so that you don't use
the kernel for two minutes just to get
one data point so here you are
submitting a get data request
and it will go to the Bloomberg service
servers and after every week you'll have
new data and you'll get you'll handle it
on these function you'll print it in
this case it out that's the demo if you
already have the response ID you get
result rather quickly and you can
redeploy tasks so because we have these
tasks on the Bloomberg
server which ran either weekly bi-weekly
monthly half yearly the these are on
Bloomberg service so you can actually
get these and then redeploy them on your
stuff so from blunders but Bloomberg's
perspective these tasks are already
running and in my case I have like 192
tasks over there I mean I just do
testing so that's why I have so many and
I can redeploy them so here's what I was
talking about I'm here getting the last
price for Vodafone London equity it is
taking 53 seconds just to get that price
and this actually explains how what is
the how the AP internals of the API are
and what is the limitation whoa
there's no live data sorry so if you
don't have live data you want live data
you go to Bloomberg terminal and you you
need Bloomberg terminal subscription for
it so you connect it using I'm going to
be brave and who knows what will happen
I don't think I should have been brave
it should work unless I'm not connected
to the Internet oh there you are
it is alright okay so
once you connect it is again hooked into
the entity framework you you can get all
these properties from it you can get
reference data because it's hooked up
into entity property you can have these
nice-looking associations historical
data so entity framework take data now
take data because you know you you can't
use the time series to actually
represent sir we use event series a
built-in function built-in data
structure to work with statistical
methods and whatnot you can get market
power high low close volume for
everything and now if you don't like the
entity framework and if you find it
cumbersome and you kind of want to get
just the raw data you can use service
execute framework and this gets you a
little bit lower - closer to the metals
as the saying goes so you get you know
you can ask for Twitter sentiment you
can get the description offered so what
annoys service actually here's an
example for historical data dictator
fans looking for data and now we are
back to a synchronous stuff we want to
get here's an example so you know when I
was trying to connect to the Bloomberg
initially and I was talking about being
brave and whatnot what is happening is
that it was getting all these fearless
together and you saw how many fifty
thousand awesome thing so here's an
example say that keeps on updating so I
can do you know one plus
one and if all goes well I can still
compute I'm not going my kernel is not
blocked and whilst this data is arriving
no she has an example for when we
initially released well from finance
platform it was only available on
Windows because we only had Bloomberg
terminal and so it only worked on
Windows but now we we support blue B
pipe will be supports every PI and it
will work on all three platforms and we
also have and bloom by DT licenses just
HTTP protocol so it's supported on all
platforms well as long as these are
those three platforms okay Android and
Reuters is I didn't talk about Reuters
but it is supported it is supported on
Windows and Linux okay all right so no
ok so while I was working on this I mean
a lot of people are interested in
writing high-performance code and they
want to write compile stuff and they
they want to call functions from
external libraries and whatnot so what
I've done is that I've used the compiler
technology to actually get data from
Bloomberg so I'm going to go through the
example it's a top-down approach and I'm
going to now close your eyes I'm going
to do something interesting
ok now you can open your eyes and be on
the first slide
make something move yeah so now you have
many many questions and say okay fine
current image looks cooler than deaths
and you'd kind of be right I mean this
is just market data and so Q well as the
data structure okay and that that's kind
of a flippant answer but we will move
out and what does this get data function
it's a component code function actually
and how am i doing there so say what is
the implementation of it here and now
you're saying well you've just that
doesn't answer anything what is this get
string from Q stuff and that's the
implementation of it I think idle
actually talked a little bit about and
there you have it you Q is a proper data
structure that you you're familiar with
you can get from it you can peek in it
and that's the API right there and all
is doing is that we are putting data and
here it is so how where did it magically
appear from well when I asked you to
close your eyes I was doing this thingy
start subscription and it returns a Q ok
and star subscription is also compile
code function his here's what's going on
so this is the actual implementation of
the star subscription function that I
that returns the Q so think that's the
code I Q new port I am putting some
stuff there
and so this is just a process event is
just a callback functional I'll talk
about that but the code is just as
simple as this actually that us what's
going on I start the session I save then
process event queue and all this and
I'll talk about each of them so argument
configure session as well
you can pass functions around you you
know you can do that just a callback
function what happens is that when I do
star subscription
it's an async service so Bloomberg is
starting a thread and I'm passing queue
to it and whenever it has data it will
put stuff in it and how it puts data
well the process event does start the
logic is in processing and the callback
okay so in that thread Bloomberg is
going to call the process event and it's
going to supply the queue and process
event can do whatever with it it can
ignore it it can put stuff in it and so
on so well this is all C C++ okay I can
show you a little bit of it here's an
example this is from Bloomberg as
Bloomberg's code it since a C++ that's
what you're seeing in Mathematica so
this is compiled right obviously so
where are these well these are actually
we can call C functions directly from
the library we can do that and if you
want to learn more you can look at this
for example I can go here and this is
actually an API I wrote all these tools
it's all top level and
I do
I'm going to ask for print actually here
so I just say it's an external function
I'm going to call it and it takes
another callback function and so on
right so what I'm doing over there is in
the callback function I am printing
stuff to end
guess what stream is the answer is Q
okay I'm not going to be very fancy Bo
but I'm putting stuff in that it's a bad
name I should have changed it for this
presentation but I did not okay
now can I get there by Candlelight how
can I do this how how you're interested
in an external library you want to write
stuff so this is the stuff that you know
I have access to Tallman Abdul so I just
talked to them and but a lot of this
stuff is documented and it's documented
in the compiler menu it says you can go
to the help and go to documentation you
go down add ons and packages compile
your manual so it it talks about quite a
few of these concepts right there as it
is a couple of Tom okay so maybe I
should I mean this is there okay and I
particularly I mean this might be just
more focused to as internal folks and I
I find this particular page quite useful
casting because you know I look at some
C code and I'm trying to figure out how
do I call it and I get but now I this is
a good starting point like if I don't
know what a pointer is I just avoid
handle okay
and obviously there's a reason for it
but so this is like you see a see
function it looks like this what would
be the Wolfram analog of it so that's
that's what it kind of looks like I like
to be too literal
so X pointer pointed like two stars and
this is how I am passing it to and I use
the FF exploratory just sometimes you
know what happens is that the API is the
C++ API but you have a DLL okay and
sometimes they don't tell you very well
that actually there are these C
functions that you can call so on
Windows C FFX pillar works rather well
here's an example so I got started out
here so I looked at the DLL and I saw
that BLP API element print I don't know
what the answer to that what arguments
had Taric I I just looked at the header
files figured out what happens but then
eventually I learned that long ago
Bloomberg had a PDF that actually talks
about all of this in proper way that
that's how I really wide these things
and some of the other things that helped
me were like this I write some simple
examples like I was having issues with
the callback functions you know how do I
return these things how do I pass them
so I wrote an example return a number
from a callback function and here's what
I did so I I wrote this example and here
so you know this is actually a C
function I I can
so it returns 9001 but I can pass my own
function that I rated wrote in top level
and now it will return 9,000 - so I do
these experiments to help me along the
way to figure things out and compile
things and write more tools so anyway
said that that's really it thank you
as far as this goes so thank you yep
questions yes I I got a license III
don't follow the question sorry yes yes
that's your old base blp API sorry if
you have B pipe server api or whatever
stuff except for Bloomberg data license
so you can use it and I think will I use
it as an example for the compiler
technology but you can do it with any
external libraries and Bloomberg is free
okay not the service but the API you can
get the dll anyone can and you can just
start coding it's the you can compile it
and all of this is accessible so the
licensing that the DLL is open so you
can compile this code today
you don't need subscription but that's
all I'm saying
anything engineer sorry - okay thank you
you